I personally have experience and
hopefully it resonates with somebody but
some level of
denial and maybe even like shame around
not being like fully integrated as a man
really and how how did that show up
uh just not not really having
availability to vulnerably look at
myself in something that's like not a
like a full so your own shame not
someone else making you feel shameful no
no yeah me feeling subconsciously
ashamed
because oh I'm still kind of like locked
in Old hurt boy modes in certain in
certain ways but how did you become
aware that's beautiful therapy
yes I think I think is somatically based
therapy particularly you know so there's
there's different versions of that
there's semantic experiencing would be
something akomi method would be
something
um also EMDR is an example of that at
all yeah oh is that a somatic really
somatic just means of the body so so if
you're doing a talk therapy or it's just
two Talking Heads talking about the
things in their heads yeah I personally
don't get a ton of value from that
because it feels more like a person
giving you fish compared to leading you
to water and teaching you how to fish
and I believe that when you when you are
working from a place with a a skilled
practitioner who is able to observe
where are you manifesting some type of
contraction or sensitivity or like
quote-unquote trigger of sorts where
you're like whoa like notice your eyes
change a little bit notice you're kind
of like self-soothing notice your voice
went up a little bit when you said that
like let's stay with that there's
something there
and they're like okay maybe close your
eyes let's like okay now bring your
awareness out of your head out of your
story and you know let's just bring your
awareness into your chest and just
breathe there you don't need to do
anything okay remember maybe bring your
worst into your abdomen your belly you
know you don't understand we're not
doing anything you know and just feeling
into that space and just notice if
anything comes up for you and notice
maybe if there's any relationship to
um you know you could maybe you you feel
anxious maybe you feel depressed maybe
you have some type of like addictive
behavior there's a way to track the
origins of that in the body
and if we can be open and vulnerable
enough to kind of open up our chest
and or open up our abdomen or open up
our pelvic floor
and say like okay like you know what do
you have anything to say anxiety do you
have anything to say sleeplessness do
you have anything to say obesity or
irritable bowel syndrome or anger old
repressed rage you have anything to
share
and then when if you have the
availability and the vulnerability
um and and like the safety and the and
typically the guidance
to do that it's like oh you have a lot
to say yeah I had no idea because I
haven't really had the capacity or know
how to listen and when you if you and
then once that Journey Begins then you
realize it's validated
and you're like okay all the stuff that
I thought was just a bunch of like new
age like Hui
actually is rooted in something pretty
interesting and something pretty
impactful that's the reason so many
people are so popped up on it it's just
usually language language and deep
visceral somatic experience it's it's
not the easiest to bridge that sometimes
there's certain people that can bridge
that well
and they're I think really valuable in
culture
um but for the most part it's kind of a
lot of people it's just it's hard to
explain have you heard of Dr Ayman yeah
I've had one podcast a couple couple
times I've worked with them a little I
interviewed him as well after I went and
had a brain scan and I was having a
conversation with him he just was like
it was a great thing to recommend make a
list of your top 10 traumas and then
just go into EMDR and deal with them and
I don't remember any memory that uh in
the original form after EMDR I only
remember how I saw it in EMDR yeah
memory is interesting the the idea of
like like what is memory in the first
place
kind of gets in like what is time you
know but like memory is a recapitulation
of It's A Memory of a memory of a memory
of a memory so you can you can develop a
story about a thing and you see this
happen in court cases regularly which is
why there's a lot of people that are in
jail for their whole life unjustly
because someone had a memory uh I was
definitely that person is like nope your
memory was not even close so it goes It
goes through filters it's painted by
your trauma I would say largely yeah
yeah so I think that the trauma is the
part I think if a person if there was
two people that were completely unpacked
let's say that's a possibility my sense
is probably there their objective
experience of the world around them
would be pretty similar in a lot of ways
it would be clear
the the
angle that I come in to any of these
conversations it really is physicality
so okay your back hurts you lack
shoulder range of motion you have
shoulder pain shoulder impended syndrome
you know your hips feel stiff your
ankles don't move right uh you don't
you're limited and you're running uh you
feel just achy aches and pains and you
just like like crepitus in your body
it's like that to me is my starting
point because I feel like that's a great
door into all the conversations it gets
into nutrition it gets into physical
movement unless you're already you've
already like drank the Kool-Aid of
conversations like this I think it's
hard for a person to be like that's
really interesting but I have to I'm
behind on my rent
um I'm freaking out about my
ex-girlfriend or girlfriend I have two
kids they need to be fed uh my back is
in terrible pain uh I can barely get out
of bed in the morning like all this
spiritual
psychosomatic neuroendo whatever is like
I this is this is where I'm at yeah you
you sort of look at the body as
essentially like the gateway drug to
more what I would call a holistic life I
think people I think people maybe three
of people's top things would be uh
Health relationships and money those are
three pain points where it's like I
think spirituality you know and all that
stuff I I don't think that's high in the
ranking of of Western culture at least
if you were to sort of break it down for
people for a couple of really beneficial
physical
um activities and then a couple of
really beneficial mental emotional
activities how would you guide people to
the next level of their awareness of
themselves I think just you could just
say the physical and that would be like
tie in with the mental emotional
obviously like I said like I think
getting therapy is a good idea if you
have a good therapist I think just
seeing someone just talking about your
problems like it could be really good
but I think it really comes like vetting
out a therapist you know EMDR is a is a
physical practice you know so if you're
taking a walk the way that EMDR was
discovered from my understanding was the
the founder she discovered it from
taking a walk and noticing the effect of
scanning The Horizon and as you're
scanning The Horizon you're going back
and forth you're looking and you're
walking and you're moving that's sending
the signal to your deep autonomic State
your your deep physiology that oh you're
moving towards progress
compared to I'm being attacked you know
and I feel Frozen you know there's a
there's fight flight and then there's
freeze like that's another aspect of
that cycle if a person has the
opportunity to actually like move their
body and look up look up into the clouds
scan the Horizon back and forth like
mobilize yourself that's sending a deep
signal that you're moving towards
progress
so it's it is an emotional experience
like that's why a lot of the best ideas
come from a person taking a walk that's
why Steve Jobs you know invested
millions of dollars on having a walking
path outside of their facility so that
his employees could go be creative and
take a walk and get sunlight and get
outside that would be one thing I would
say just like get outside
you know most of the modern diseases
uh there you could refer to them as as
diseases of mismatch and what that means
is is just our physiology is mismatched
to this modern environment that we
created so we created this really
convenient environment but we neglected
the fact that a lot of that
inconvenience is actually what turns us
at a cellular level so now we take that
off of the table and now we Outsource
all of that healing movement to
technology and we just get kind of like
stuck up in claustrophobic and
dehydrated in our own cells
you need to move you need to express in
order to be healthy it's just the way
that it is yeah yeah so so easy ways to
do that I would say would would be and
this is like I wrote a whole book about
this essentially is how to integrate
Fitness into who you are as a person as
opposed to it being like this
compartmentalized thing that you do
three days a week
um you know your whole day is Fitness
and so an example of that be like take
walking meetings
um you're getting natural sunlight you
know full spectrum sunlight as opposed
to sunlight through a window which
you're blocking out a certain spectrum
of the light uh
so that's a big deal as well so you need
to get out of just because you have a
window in your house it's better than
not having a window but you need full
spectrum sunlight it's like eating a
supplemented form of food it's just you
just need food like your body runs on
sun yeah so so
um you know sunlight like incorporating
that into your quote Fitness walking is
a really beautiful way to help with
consolidation of memories so if you're
working on like a hard problem of some
sort or just work in general you're
studying for a test or something uh
maybe study hard for some duration of
time that feels good for you and then
intense to say cool instead of taking a
break from this and checking my
notifications on my phone and like kind
of dilapidating myself over into this
position and staring into my phone I'm
going to intentionally walk outside move
my body integrate the hemispheres of my
brain slash the rest of my body and
reflect for a moment and like process
like that's that's walking's one of the
greatest things you can do for yourself
sunlight I would say is probably the
First Sunlight nutrition and then
Community I would say like the base
fundamentals like you need to eat and
you need sunlight next is community
period there's nothing it's not money
it's not it's like you need Community
meaning makes money you don't make money
without Community you don't make money
alone if you like this clip and you want
to hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen